today on our show team switching man
swapping out key parties in the comic
book movie universe Joss Whedon goes to
DC Tom Hardy goes to Marvel what's going
on in the world kids tell that today and
so much more I'm fattening on Batman
that men on Batman welcome to Batman I'm
Batman I'm Kevin mark barnard you know I
always get a lot of complaints mark
Bernard no like you guys don't talk
enough about Batman so let's lead with a
Batman thought right away
I just rewatch Lego Batman this morning
at you did everything you needed to
doing more oh my god it's so wonderful
it's like it's it's porn if you're a
Batman fan like all the best parts of
Batman celebrated kind of poked it's
like a Batman Roast warm and wonderful
and fuzzy at the end like it's it's
superb and my hats off to that whole
team any event that that wasn't but it
connects tell me they got a vehicle in
that thing called the Scuttler even like
climbs like a bat yeah isn't that what's
in that channel a trailer Batman like
monitor and it jumps and if they work
like climb no toys yeah I guess or
they're like this is now part of the
Batman unit its cannon it's a walking
vehicle which lies it's a batwing but
then also when it lands it can like a
bat does because that is the most
efficient way to ambulate across a flat
surface and you're a billionaire do
whatever you want but I got I mean I
have a flying thing or a driving thing
or a walking thing because that's what I
was been seven billion dollars to build
I want to build something lumbers I mean
I could walk I'm free that it literally
I think it is the same vehicle enclosing
any event that brings us to the Justice
League and the news last week that Joss
Whedon was going to be stepping in to
pick up reshoots on the Justice League
movie for a heartbreaking reason yeah
Zack Snyder having the worst you know
family trouble I guess someone could
have like unimaginable painful situation
we won't dive into it here but for a
really good reason he has got to
concentrate on real life you know work
those of us in this business and those
of us particularly on that business in
the other side of able to make the big
movies very very lucky to make pretend
for a living so spend most of your life
trying to do that very thing like why be
an adult
let's make pretend if you can get paid
for it
you've cracked the code of the universe
and stuff but you know every once in a
while real life like absolutely intrudes
on the making believe and Jack had
something very real very horrible very
tragic epitone my heart goes out to him
uh and his entire family
absolutely and like the perspective of
it is absolutely legitimate it's I have
to deal I got to get my house back in
order I have to adapt to deal with grief
and tragedy and awfulness and that's
just a movie yeah again he said it like
this of course it's a great movie I love
this movie but it's just a movie and
he's like think about it like I know
there's lots of money and stuff like
that but like you know families forever
this flick one day you're going to watch
it on your phone while you're like in
the bathroom we're waiting for a flight
like oh I'll rewatch that one scene like
that's how disposable this all becomes
when you're in the moment of making
you're like we're mega grand our even yo
Gosar's you look we're making grand art
we're making a statement and you forget
that one day like it wants you lucky if
it winds up on a phone or something like
that it just doesn't really you know
matter in the grand scheme of things
compared to human beings and loved ones
so yeah unimaginable to deal with what
he's had to deal with and and and the
smartest thing in the world anyone could
do is let him go deal with the Amer and
I want a brothers has by all accounts
been super chill about all this like you
do what you need to do whatever you need
to do do you want to push the movie back
we'll push it back do you want we can
put it on hold whatever you need and Zak
said no listen it's it's a good movie it
deserves to be seen the fans to have it
when they should have it and we got this
guy sitting right here working on
Batgirl he can absolutely like he was
writing scenes anyway like they were
they were reshoots that they were doing
they attested the movie and they
realized they were a couple of key
scenes that needed some help and he
drafted Joss to write those things could
you imagine like what a great idea yeah
cool I do it off the bench like hey
brilliant person could yeah I wonder is
you got an experience we're a team it's
like so BAM they got the guy right in
their corner and it looks like you know
even in the wake of the poor
being the internet some people said this
that or the other thing the fact of the
matter is like you're getting the
Justice League movie it is Zack's
Justice League movie from start to
finish
Joss is coming in to help out and stuff
but like you know this is a man's vision
and it's heartbreaking that he has to
step away from it you know again I make
movies I make very little movies that
are [ __ ] disposable and sure like
that you make it something like this the
eyes of the world are upon you a lot of
financial pressures upon you and stuff
like that and and none of that matters
in comparison to real life and Zach I've
hit very hard by real life yeah yeah and
the internet does what the internet does
which is by turns be incredibly warm in
supporting which I saw a lot of I saw a
ton of like oh my god like I can't a lot
of people put away they're like you know
haterade for a moment to just feel like
I can't even imagine it's all fun and
games you know about like Marvel vs. DC
or whatever until something very
collapse yeah and I did see in
overwhelmingly a lot of positive no love
thrown the totally totally I mean and
that's the thing like I I personally
have been somewhat critical of Zacks
movies and that's fine those are movies
that's the product that he makes he puts
out into the world and I'm entitled to
feel what I feel but this depth of
anguish and agony that he's going
through just as a human being like my
god I can't imagine an out of the always
dealing with and that is entirely
divorced from whatever anybody thinks
for the movies it's holy [ __ ] like I
just want to give a guy a hug and tell
him it'll be okay or maybe it won't I
don't know I've never been that his wife
was his producer he works with all the
time and all of his kids he's got he's
got a good family some take the time you
need man get you get your head straight
get your heart right but when we see
that movie we know it's going to be
yours
we know it's sex movie we know like yeah
go take care which is not waiting for us
he is gonna take care of them so but but
I'm there I can't wait and still Eagers
[ __ ] to see this movie probably more so
now that we've seen Wonder Woman which
we'll talk about
in a future episode there's an embargo
we can't tell you what we think until
but so an episode or two from now ah
it's like all that [ __ ] lasso on us
and we'll be like true we all truth
alright so Justice League right now
getting I mean you know the underlying
story to that to the main bad story is
that Joss Whedon's coming in to do seems
excessively like he's going to finish it
up he's going to he's going to take it
from third base to home which is really
sweet you're gonna go if you're gonna
turn to a guy he's got a wee bit
experience in this burg absolutely okay
moving on yes
the from one marvel man goes to DC
Universe flipped that DC man goes to
Marv we need choreograph that that's
just Matt hi-hat we can synchronize
swimmed our way to metal if I don't
watch my take off our shirts in the pool
so apparently that ain't gotta [ __ ]
happen nope this is the metal weekend
this is a metal t-shirts we wear in the
pool I'll tell you right now Tom Hardy
as venom which is old news but you're
gonna celebrate it here that I mean come
on like I didn't wanna vent a movie at
all until you tell me that Tom Hardy's
playing venom bang there's a review for
somebody said on Twitter because I
talked about it on Hollywood babble-on
but somebody's like you guys missed the
obvious joke venom was what Bane took to
become vain in the comics and now he's
playing venom not a joke but more of an
observation a more talented funny person
like the people that wrote that Batman
lego movie they would have been able to
make a meal of that but I thought it was
just no that's interesting looks like
he's getting a high on himself okay
that's my [ __ ] time he's gonna card so
this is actually pretty sick very good
okay
the it's it's that's phenomenal yeah and
you know the guys directing it ruben
fleischer yeah he directed a zombie
lands wonderful yeah which any directed
was a gang of Pat Squad movie
oh thanks for Squad we can just call
head squad hat squad the building pad
squad movie yeah and the one this one
had Ryan Reynolds yeah Ryan Browns Ryan
Gosling
not the ABC TV show called head squad
during Lynette no that's a crime squad
but it was also kind of I wasn't totally
that's what
what do I mean that's what we all call a
job antenna in a hack it's a different
story over and over again like one time
in LA they used to throw people off a
[ __ ] cliff like that enough to
sustain a movie like it's enough to
sustain a series of movies and
television show we're going to do this
every 10 years for the rest of time well
good for Ruben he's out of movie Jail
which is where I think they might have
put him after them pretty much and then
now he gets to play with venom and that
gives AMI lands an amazing movie so they
keep talking about a sequel to that
which I would watch in a heartbeat and
who the hell knows what the holdup is
I'm all for this I'm all for the casting
of this I'm all for the director of this
and like you said like prior to this I
was like yeah I mean I guess venom movie
sure why not it seems weird to reboot
that not as a spin-off as priming but
I'm sure you know what you're doing and
I'll say it I'm in the bag for the [ __ ]
anyway I love comic book movies but now
that it is Tom Hardy I'm like go on do -
what will the voice be explain it to me
I wouldn't be amazing he's like blasted
would Tom Hardy is the viewers like last
time I picked an old-timey [ __ ]
scrapper stole his voice you know
prevent him I'm gonna go differently
like he went the other way we all
expected BAM would be like I woke Batman
or whatever but it was just like I got a
blank on Iraqi ground reports both so
it's a good like a a highfalutin genteel
man of leisure or he's like I picked a
old polish grandmother stole her voice
for venom what do you get
come on you get T up front and present
like that and not deliver you have bread
years and years ago when Fred was hard
to come back this is exciting news yeah
mark and once again what a great time to
be alive and they are sprinting to make
this thing happen like it the release
date is October 2018 they're about to
have all the heat from that [ __ ]
spider-man movie which they put a third
trailer for spider-man homecoming and
every one of them has be shooting
websley all three of those trailers
- go trailers are fantastic and there's
one trailer so I don't know if it's a
fourth trailer but maybe it's an
international trailer has a lot of
Michael Keaton and the store
three of what they're doing bad guys are
doing so this this movie if my kid was
talking about the other day she's like
that movies gonna make so much money I
was like well yeah it's spider-man she
was not because that is because he's in
high school oh yeah she's like
everyone's talking about this which is
graduate high school so I know what they
were talking about when you graduated
tell me what the children say we spent a
lot of money on your [ __ ] education
all you were talking about his pocket
spider-man how well it's gonna do we got
our skin in the game I said about
theorems an equation yeah so I you know
my kids a prognosticator I movie's gonna
make a lot of money and I saw how thick
and Sony is also developing a black cat
silver sable movie Felicia Hardy Felicia
Hardy and yes silver sable I've never
had it
no Jesus she's a character but her name
literally is silver sable laughs that's
good job handsome yeah wait a code name
with the [ __ ] parents wait good job
silver sable for not going like you know
maybe I should be black cat no please
Hardy's like that's me I got that I felt
like of it it's the spider-man universe
is expanding right you get venom on one
hand and you're going to get the sort of
lady crying duo team-up silver and black
is what they're calling it because
silver black silver black yeah not bad
Wow that that is like really they're not
even used they're not even gonna spin
them off of the spider-man movie there's
gonna go for it yet just silver black I
mean maybe they show up in homecoming
who knows Sony's like we got the entire
toy box while I was sitting on like the
one character putting them out every few
years [ __ ] let's do the whole
universe right now I'd watch on scorpion
movie man I you know movie I'm waiting
for if they're going to play with the
toys pull out Mysterio no it's kind of
wondering it one day they're going to
realize oh we have a movie villain
that's predicated on movie we have a
villain spider-man well it's predicated
on movie special effects he came from
the world of movies special effects and
what do we do in this world but movie
special effects and yet you can explain
away everything he does look like it was
an illusion and [ __ ] like that one day
they're going to grab on Mysterio and
ride him to two billion dollars at the
box office because who don't love bubble
head toughen a new year and you get some
giant [ __ ] a-list star to plan
because all he's got to do is show for
three days on a set and he's in a booth
do an ad offer there sometimes they
shootin like Robert Downey when he's in
the
even with them in there so they can get
some glory shots and whoever they paid
Johnny Depp is Mysterio fee makes all
the sense in the world jingling shushing
take it there's going to be we got
Johnny Depp news for you next episode
whoo at the t's that's a team is wrapped
and will give the rest of them next
episode all right there it is man as
some news go about your day with that
news go tell people tell them where you
heard it right here on fat man I'm
Batman for fat man how about men I'm
Kevin Smith but I am moderately but not
come back next episode same bat-time
same bat-channel smokers calm or
youtube.com slash cabin Smith
[Music]